hey uncle joe i'm a little strapped for  cash and my mom's kicking me out  so you think you can make me a waiter or  something  i got to be honest with you you are the  worst bus boy i've ever had  if it weren't for that i'd do it yeah  it's just cause this job's so easy you  know i get bored it's just all the  busboy does is say hey you don't eat  your food you know if i was a waiter i  could you know use my charisma  i saw you put a booger in the center of  that bread that you fed to your mother's  boyfriend  well what if i said i wouldn't do that  again i wouldn't believe you why don't  you just dump me now  because your dad died in a fire and  because you see potential in my future  you're my nephew i love you get back to  work no boogers all right  you're doing good today i just got here  10 minutes ago